Let us suppose that the A agent has prior knowledge of these four concepts.
A brick, a glass, a bowl,
and a briefcase. Let us look at one of these concepts in detail. So
the brick is stable because the bottom is flat. And a brick is heavy. So first,
this particular conceptual characterization has several parts. About stability
and about heaviness. Second, there is also something about causality here.
The brick is stable because its bottom is flat. This is an important element of
the brick, and similar things occur in the other four concepts.
Let us now consider how an AI agent might be able to represent all of
this knowledge about a brick. Here is a visual rendering of this representation.
First, the A agent knows about a lot facts about the brick. So a brick is heavy.
The brick has a bottom and the bottom is flat. That comes from the second part
of the first sentence. Bottom is flat. And also that the brick is stable. So
here are some observable facts and this is a property of the brick. So this is
part of the structure of the brick. This is part of its function. In addition,
the A agent knows that the brick is stable because the bottom is flat. So
we need to capture this notion of causality. So this yellow arrows here,
are intended to capture this notion of causality. The AI agent knows that
the brick is stable because the brick has a bottom and the bottom is flat. And
this way, it connects these structural features into these factional features,
to these causal connections. To take another example, here is
a conceptual characterization of a briefcase and here is it's knowledge for
representation. I'll not go through this in great detail, but
briefly, a briefcase is liftable because it has a handle and it is light.
And it is useful because it contains papers. Notice the notion of
causality here again. Once again there're these facts about the briefcase, for
example the briefcase is portable, the briefcase has a handle, you know,
these structural observable features. And then there is
this functional features like briefcase is useful and briefcase is liftable. And
then we have these yellow arrows denoting the causal connections between them.
Similarly for the bowl, here is its conceptual characterization and
the knowledge representation. So the bowl contains cherry soup that one of
the fact here. The bowl is concave, that's another fact here and
it is a causal relationship here. It carries liquid because it is concave.
Finally the fourth concept the A agent knows about, a glass. And a glass
enables drinking because it carries liquid and it is liftable, and it is pretty.
So the glass is pretty. The glass carries liquids. It is liftable. And the fact
that it enables drinking is because of these two other facts. Note quickly
that not all these structural features participate in this causal explanation.